if your idea of relaxing to see in a
horror movie Preta I've got the one for
your girlfriend because you don't get
any scarier then Jordan peels horror
flick us the cast telling me what you
see is definitely what you get okay
let's call the cops I did they're 14
minutes away we've made it very clear on
the posters that this is a nightmare so
you know if you're going to see this
movie that's what you're signing up for
Lupita and Winston Duke are a married
couple living in the mother of all bad
dreams the two first co-starred in black
panther and now they're battling some
scary home invaders who looked just like
them hey hey hey hey
was it meant to make me sleep with the
lights on last night which I did not
even lying mm-hmm and the television yes
it's meant to do all those things all at
once I think that's the power of the
movie you leave and you're uncomfortable
the movie is the first from writer
director Jordan Peele since he won a
screenwriting Oscar for get out last
year
get out made 255 million worldwide and
in this twisted tale you may have topped
himself we can give people a cheat sheet
that are going to watch this movie what
would they be I design a movie to take
an audience's expectations and to use
them against the audience people at us
go see it it is a warm family comedy
with some light romantic terms it's a
feel-good romp a romp not exactly us is
getting rave reviews for combining
horror thought-provoking drama and humor
it's very funny so you're gonna be
freaking up and you're gonna be you know
sore from holding your shoulders up but
you're also gonna really laugh yes true
so it's a good workout
[Music]
[Applause]